So let me start
by bringing you back in time.
We are 30 years ago,
and the first word processors
and spreadsheets
are about to hit the market.
And the whole economic world is bracing
for the next big productivity revolution.
Their promise at the time was
we'd all spend so much less time writing,
drawing slides, computing
numbers on a calculator.
And here we are, 30 years later,
and the promise has come true.
We all have so much
leisure time on our hands,
and personally, I only work
two days a week.
Of course, I'm just kidding.
The reality of what
has happened 30 years later
is we don't work less.
We just write much longer word documents.
And our PowerPoint decks
have gone from six slides to 50 slides.
And I say that as a consultant.
Also, we engage in much more
complex decision-making
because the amount of data
that we have to process has just exploded.
And why is that important today?
Well, generative AI is coming,
and it's coming to be embedded
in the core of our organizations
and the way we work.
And that will be the next
big productivity revolution.
So the question becomes:
how do we set ourselves up to actually
seize this productivity opportunity?
I'm a marketer.
I spent all my career in marketing
and also advising marketing professionals.
Now, some say marketing is the number one
impacted function out there.
Some say the productivity
impact in marketing
is as high as 50 percent.
So that question of how can I seize
that productivity opportunity
is super high on my mind right now,
and I want to make the case
it should be super important
to you all as well,
as business leaders
but also as consumers.
So what will happen to marketing?
Well, marketing has traditionally
been a super right-brained,
creative type of function.
That means what?
Means we have excelled as marketers
by tapping into the emotional
needs of our consumers,
coming up with that perfect product,
that perfect innovation to meet that need,
and also then cracking that great message
that will convert the consumer
at the right place in the right time.
Already in the past 15 years,
with digital marketing and analytics,
marketing has evolved from being
only right-brain type of general skills
to a few more specialized skill sets,
for example, digital marketing
or marketing technology.
But now the difference with generative AI,
it is transforming the core
of marketing activities.
Now, in a recent study
that the Boston Consulting Group
conducted with Harvard,
we found that ChatGPT,
in its current form,
already improves the right-brain
performance of marketers by 40 percent.
Imagine what that number will be
in a year or two from now.
So what do you think marketers would do
with a day and a half of free time a week?
More yoga?
More family time?
Do you think companies would allow that?
Or do you think companies will just let
large chunks of the marketing function go?
Well, I believe none of this
is going to happen.
I think if we don't steer
that productivity revolution
very actively,
marketers will invest this time
in what they do best:
more content and more ideas.
Now, if you think of more content,
there is a super productive outcome
for all of us as consumers.
More content actually means
much more personalized content.
Now think of that email
that you're getting from your
favorite brand every week.
Imagine if that email
was 100 percent tailored to you,
means only images of people
your age and gender,
even people wearing T-shirts
of your favorite rock band,
every product relevant for you,
and even a human-like experience
powered by a bot.
That is certainly a productive outcome.
But there is also a very negative outcome
for us consumers here,
and that is content overload.
How many of you already feel chased
by the same content
over and over again online?
Now imagine if that content chasing you,
if that amount of content
chasing you just explodes.
And imagine if that content chasing you
also all sounds the same.
Now why is that a risk?
Generative AI has been trained
on existing content and data.
Because of that, it reduces
divergence of outcomes.
And that great equalization of marketing
is certainly not a productive outcome.
So what is the solve here?
Well, I believe marketing,
but also every function out there
that is being impacted
by this productivity revolution,
needs to grow a left-AI brain,
grow one fast,
and also identify and protect
its top right-brained talent.
You're going to ask me,
"What do you mean
by growing a left-AI brain?"
Well, I mean, the function needs
to strategically reskill and reorganize
to embed people that can build,
use and diffuse predictive AI tools
in the heart of decision-making.
I mean, for marketing, building teams
of marketing data scientists,
marketing data engineers
that build solutions
that can be distributed to all marketers
to, for example, unpack performance
and predict outcomes.
Imagine in marketing
being able to understand
what audience creative couples
are really hitting it off in the market,
or what product is working
with which consumer and why
or how is the marketing funnel evolving.
I recently partnered with a consumer goods
company that did exactly that.
They decided to grow
a left-AI brain advantage.
We helped them build tools
that were diffused
in the entire organization,
that helped every marketer predict
for every marketing initiative
what was going to be the sales outcome,
how a consumer behavior is going to be
impacted on every channel
and every touchpoint,
and go deep in unpacking
execution insights
to understand what creative
was working and why.
That created a super virtuous feedback
loop in the entire organization.
It also took building a team of 30-plus
left-AI brain marketers
that build these tools, customize them,
but also in turn upskill the entire
organization to use them.
But the team's only a part of the puzzle.
I see too many companies out there
embarking on this journey,
just training their algorithms and models
only on their current content and data.
Now, if you do that,
the risk for a brand is to be trapped
in your current territory.
Concretely, imagine you are a brand
that is super strong with millennials.
There is nothing in data and content
existing on millennials
that will help you
to be successful with Gen Z.
And in turn, if you're never
successful with Gen Z,
you will miss out on important
innovations and trends
that will make you
stronger with millennials.
So I advise every company out there:
think outside of the box,
think outside your direct ecosystem
on who could be super relevant
data and content partners for you.
Imagine you're a construction company
and you decide to market
to architects for the first time.
You have zero data on architects.
What do you do?
Who has data on architects?
Other construction companies,
but they're direct competitors.
So where do you go?
Well, you go outside your ecosystem,
potentially, for example,
with financial institutions, insurances.
You can set up a federated
model with them,
train algos on that,
that will in turn make you much stronger
to market to a new consumer segment.
And so are you done?
If you have that, if you have that data,
if you have those skills
are you done, you have
that left-AI brain advantage?
Well, no, actually you are not.
If you do that, there is a risk
you give all of your right brain
to generative AI
and in turn run a real risk
of losing that divergence,
losing that super strong brand identity,
being trapped in that grand
equalization of marketing
I was talking about a minute ago.
In the Harvard study we conducted
with the Boston Consulting
Group and Harvard,
we found that when people
over-rely on generative AI,
the collective divergence of ideas
drops by 40 percent.
Concretely, that means that new ideas
don't come to the surface.
It means that true innovation
is being stifled.
So what is a solve here?
Well, you need to identify
the true artists,
the true differentiators,
the true innovators of your function.
Now, if you've ever worked in marketing,
you know who these people are.
They are the ones that always
disagree with you.
Now you take these people
and you need to strategically
reskill them to use AI well,
for example, to be inspired by new ideas,
to be inspired by new trends,
to also crack fast prototypes,
to multiply their impact
once they've cracked a great idea.
But you need to protect them
and teach them
from using the AI to generate
and originate original ideas.
For that, they have to use
their human brain.
To keep those human juices flowing,
and that, in turn, will protect
the identity of your brand
and your differentiation in the market.
So I want to close with an advice
for any marketer out there.
What are you good at?
Are you super creative?
Are you the true innovator in the room?
Well, if you are, cultivate that.
That will be your superpower.
Do you like data?
Are you super rational,
are you super fact-based?
Then you should specialize.
You should grow tech skills.
You should be investing
in predictive AI competencies.
But right now, every marketer out there
needs to choose their brain.
Thank you.
(Applause)